[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER 1: Today, we have JD
Stier, Kwame Marfo, and Jim
[INAUDIBLE].
Three of them are
here to provide
three different unique
perspectives on the issues
that we're going to see
in this documentary.
JD is the Director of the
campaign Stand With Congo.
And Kwame Marfo
has vast experience
working in development
investments
across the African continent.
And then we have Jim, who
is a national of the DRC,
and he'll kind of give us that
perspective of someone who has
lived and seen this firsthand.
So when we have the
panelists, they'll
just give a kind of
spiel and tell you
what their perspectives
are on the issues.
Afterwards, we'll open up
for questions, anything
that you want to ask
or want to learn about.
JD STIER: I produced this
film in part to educate.
Sitting here at
Google headquarters,
I think being cognizant of
the impact all us broadly
are having through
our technology sector,
it's important to be aware.
But primary motivation
is to really demonstrate
the human impact that our
previous practices have
had on life, and that it just
doesn't need to be this way.
We can advance our society
without having a harmful impact
on humanity or the environment.
There's lots of examples of this
in Congo now in recent years.
In 2012, we really focused our
activist efforts on Apple--
the world's largest device
manufacturer at the time--
and Intel--
the world's largest chip
manufacturer-- and calling
for positive reform,
calling for positive change.
We organized on 165
campuses that year.
Apple's CEO, Jobs and then
Cook and then Brian Krzanich,
at Intel, leapt
at the opportunity
to do the right thing.
They really did.
When they became aware of
this, these individuals
moved their companies
in the right direction.
And Brian Krzanich at
CES in January of 2013
took the stage
with Robin Wright,
who I had the honor of
taking to Congo back in 2011.
And she's been a strong
advocate for well
over a decade for
women and girls
who are paying the largest
price for this in Congo.
And Brian announced
at CES that every chip
they shipped from
that moment forward
would be Congo conflict-free.
Apple, doing what Apple
does, said, OK, we
want to do the right thing.
And then they
disappeared for a while,
never heard anything
from them again.
They came back in 2014 and
had the largest publish
of their supply chain
ever, as a big transparency
measure for them.
So each of these
companies took big strides
for the right reasons.
So your sector is a relatively
small player in the minerals
trade out of Congo.
You heard from
strategic minerals
and military to heavy machinery,
aeronautics, and other sectors,
but it's your industry
that's leading the way.
And your industry is now
becoming the role model
that us activists get to take
when we go now directly talking
to mining companies and others.
With Google having
relatively recently emerged
as a leading player, a strong
force in the device space,
you're off to a
phenomenal start,
but you also have
the opportunity
to kind of create a new way
to engage on this issue.
Being the newest players and
the one of the biggest players,
you can really double down
and can double down on the way
in which you're confronting
the supply chain issue
and how it relates to
transparency, government
corruption, and the like.
I wanted to say three very
concrete things that we can
do together to have an impact.
Number one, signing the
petition at StandWithCongo.org,
so tech is not alone.
We're asking government
leaders to make it
an industry-wide,
minerals-wide effort.
So it's not just falling
on tech's shoulders,
sharing that petition
in your networks.
Number two is raising awareness.
Stand With Congo is eager
to partner with entities--
Google would be
chief among them--
to raise awareness in
Congo and internationally.
This is our 116th
screening event
in 17 countries in
just under a year.
We launched together.
We were all together on May
16 at the Tribeca Film Center
to launch this campaign.
116 events and 17
countries later,
we've met from LSE in Oxford
to Colombia and inside Congo
and throughout Belgium and from
Jakarta to Cyprus to Tel Aviv.
The world is very much paying
attention to tech minerals
but getting beyond that, how
we as millennials, as leaders,
can use technology,
can use our platforms,
can use our resources
through our employers
to raise awareness,
to plan events,
to plan community
engagement events.
Third-- sign the
petition, raise awareness,
and I think I'd really
love to have conversations
with folks here about ways
in which we can partner
to bring events to schools,
to bring events to students,
and find a way for
Google to speak
about the steps it's taking.
Private sector
solutions are really
the way that we're going
to pave a new path,
and you're going to be hearing
about this from our panelists
tonight.
The last way that we can have a
real impact is direct support.
I would love at
some point for Jim
to mention a project
that he's piloting
through his organization
in partnership
with Stand With Congo as
a way for business leaders
to really help boost human
capital and capacity in Congo.
So from direct
support, mentorship,
to hardware and software,
the needs are there,
and we have the facility and the
connections and relationships
to be able to facilitate
that kind of direct support.
And so looking forward
to engaging Q&A
with everybody online, but
I'd like to now kick it over
to Kwame, who is our
international executive
producer who's been a
guiding force behind bringing
this platform and this
dialogue around what
are the barriers
to entrepreneurship
on the continent--
Congo, but Africa at large--
and what are the ways
in which we can better
support a more rapid
development of the economy.
Kwame Marfo.
KWAME MARFO: Can
you guys hear me?
Hi, thank you, JD, for
your kind introduction.
So I think it might
be helpful to give you
a bit of a background on how I
got involved in this project.
So I got frustrated
with events in Africa,
and I think the easiest thing
to do is criticize, right?
And most of the criticism is
often leveled at our leaders.
I came to the view that one,
as an instrument of change,
criticism is actually a
spectacularly blunt one.
And secondly, I came to the view
that leadership, if you will,
the knowledge that really
comes to mind is will.
So you have government,
the civil society,
and there is business.
So the fact that most
governments in Africa
don't live up to
the expectations
should not preclude us from
being change agents in business
and civil society.
And one of my early
inspirations was from Nollywood
in Nigeria, which
by some estimates
is the second or third
largest employer in Nigeria.
So I grew up in Ghana.
So I had the--
I saw Nollywood basically
become an economic engine out
of nothing.
And if you studied the
industry quite well,
most of the people that
are actually driving change
have very little formal
education in filmmaking.
But they're mostly, in
Nigerian parlance, hustlers
who have been able to
create opportunities,
and Nollywood has
been able to thrive
in spite of an
ineffectual government
apparatus in Nigeria.
So my challenge to people,
like myself with fancy degrees
and work titles, was, look at--
Nollywood is getting things
done in spite of the fact
that governance in
Nigeria is not optimal,
in spite of the fact that
most them lack training.
What can we do?
So we took that
conversation further
by forming an investment
platform called
Diaspora Capital.
[INAUDIBLE] Citizen Capital from
the African diasporan community
have been able to mobilize
quite a bit of funds, invested
in countries in Ghana,
Liberia, Zambia,
and most recently, in Penang.
Along the way, in spite
of your best efforts,
we run into a number of issues
that affected our ability
to do business.
So I was working on
chronicling the challenges
that we face as investors
and also the businesses
we invest in in doing
business in Africa.
And the goal was to convert
the lessons into an easily
digestible visual format--
i.e. a documentary-- with
a case study on the Congo,
and that is when I run
into JD and his team.
And they already had their
well-developed product
so I felt it probably would
make sense to work with them
as opposed to trying
to reinvent the wheel.
So does my involvement, and one
thing I also want to emphasize
is I'm not from the Congo.
So the question
is why the Congo?
Well, first of all,
I'd like to thank
[INAUDIBLE] and the
team from Google
for giving us this
opportunity to be here.
We have tried to run this by
a number of organizations,
including African focus
organizations, and some of them
have flat out told us they
didn't see any alignment,
which I personally have
found quite perplexing.
Even from a purely
humanitarian perspective,
5.4 million people have
died from the war in Congo.
This is, to put it
in context, about 2/3
of the population of
New York or London,
bigger than the
population of Norway.
These Black Lives Matter, too.
The second point
I'd like to raise
is the fact that Congo
is too big to fail.
When I was in grad
school, one of the lessons
I learned was the best
predictor of war in a country
is war next door.
And looking at the Congo,
it's destabilizing forces
have led to nine other
countries been plunged
into one conflict or the other.
The other point I'd
like to raise also
is that strategically
speaking, I
would argue that
Congo is probably
the most strategically
important,
the most strategically important
country in Africa, at least
throughout history.
I mean, if you look at
the main events that
have shaped our
global economy, Congo
has had a say starting from
the Industrial Revolution.
The rubber that was used to
power the Industrial Revolution
was sourced from the
forest in the Congo.
Looking at the
First World War, 75%
of the brass casings
that came from the war
were sourced from the Congo.
Going down to Second
World War, the uranium up
to today in the [INAUDIBLE]
and cobalt that are
used to power mobile telephony.
So the misfortune with
the Congo is its knack
for producing the
right resources at most
critical times have lead
to a bit of a scramble
for its resources, starting
with the European colonialists
to the actors in the Cold War to
most recently local insurgency
groups.
And lastly, the reason why I
think the Congo is important
and why we should
all care is I think
there is an existential crises,
not just in Congo, but in most
of Africa, which
is a lack of jobs.
There aren't too many
examples of countries
moving from grinding poverty to
emerging or developed countries
status without having
a manufacturing base.
And the reason why
Africa's industrial hub
hasn't taken off, in spite
of the fact that we have
a number of advantages,
is due to the fact
that we don't have
access to electricity
at an affordable price.
And Congo has the resources--
I mean, the Congo River
itself has a potential
to generate up to 100,000
megawatts of electricity.
That's 13% of the world's
hydroelectric potential.
And the beauty with
the Congo River
is, unlike most river
basins in Africa, which
tend to dry out during the
dry season, the Congo River,
the [INAUDIBLE] basin sits
north and south of the equator.
So at any given
time, a part of it
experiences the rainy season.
So the only way we could
realize Congo's potential
is to create this environment
to bring the best out
of it and its people.
Thank you.
JD STIER: Thank you, Kwame.
And Kwame and I have
been doing these events
all around the world for the
better part of the past year,
and we are proud to
stand in solidarity
but give respect for the
Congolese people, for whom this
is their struggle.
And Kwame and I have
found many ways in which
we attempt to be supportive.
But now let's take a back
seat and introduce Jim,
a business leader from Congo--
and actually just returned from
a trip--
who has ushered in some amazing
new ideas and progresses,
but really, in my opinion,
is a phenomenal example
of the hope of the future, the
hope of this new generation,
and millions of young Congolese
ready to reap the benefits.
JIM N.: Thanks
for the intro, JD.
So my name is Jim [INAUDIBLE].
And just to give you a
quick background on how
I got involved on the management
team for a organization called
Young African MBAs,
and despite our name,
you don't have to
be young, African,
or have an MBA to be a member.
Those are just the
characteristics
of our founders.
And basically, we formed
a partnership with Stand
With Congo earlier this year.
We're just trying to
figure out ways to raise
awareness of this film.
And the most recent
we were in talks
right now to talk about how we
can really beyond just raising
awareness of the
film, having also
more of an impact on the
ground through mentorship
for entrepreneurs.
So that's something
we're piloting right now.
We're going to get
started very soon.
And as JD and Kwame
mentioned, I'm
from DRC so I'm very aware that
if it wasn't for who my parents
and grandparents are, I could've
been one of these victimized
kids.
So this makes me even try even
harder to find ways to make
a difference in the country
because beyond the fact that it
could be me, just even
if I wasn't from Congo,
I still feel like it's--
from a humanitarian
standpoint, it just--
it's not right.
I know life isn't fair,
but there are some things
that we shouldn't tolerate
as people living here.
So I just want to do what
I can to help change things
and really help empower the next
generation so that in 20 years,
there isn't the
next JD coming up
with another movie about the
plight of the Congolese people,
that things are actually moving
forward and there's progress
and there's hope.
So that's how I got
involved, and thank
you guys for watching.
And thanks leading a
forum, making this happen.
JD STIER: Yeah, thanks everyone
for coming out, [INAUDIBLE],,
Google.
And let's open it up
for Q&A, but could you
please come to the
microphone because we're
going to be streaming
And so please
ask any questions that you
might have into the microphone.
And we'd love to talk about
what's happening on the ground.
We'd love to talk about
entrepreneurial and business
opportunities.
We'd love to give an update
on the political situation.
So whatever curiosities you
may have, please whether it's
online in chat or
on the microphone,
we're looking forward to engage.
AUDIENCE: Hi, I don't
really know much about
Congolese politics
so I would love to--
I think I had trouble
following along because it
was pretty complicated.
I guess the current President,
his term expired last year,
but it was extended.
What was the constitutional
mechanism through that--
allowed that to happen?
And what's going to happen?
I mean, I think they had a
new Constitution in 2006.
Are they going to have
another new Constitution?
Thanks.
JIM N.: So there was no real
constitutional mechanism
for the lack of elections.
Literally, four months
before it happened,
they were like, there's
no budget for elections.
They're not going to happen.
So that really pretty
much is what happened.
They said, you know, we have
no money to finance elections.
We went through the new census
so let's just put this on hold
for a little bit.
And then there was
some chance of riots
so they, the opposition,
met with the powers that be,
and they talked about--
they found, I guess,
a temporary plan
whereas Kabila could be
the Interim President
until the next elections.
That was supposed to
happen this December,
but I was there in April.
When I asked if it's going
to happen, people laughed.
So basically, I think that
the consensus that elections
are not going to
happen this year,
but everybody is aware
that they should happen
so just a matter of I
guess how far they're
willing to hold
onto power and what
they're willing to do to
make sure the elections never
happen.
But really there
was no mechanism.
Really just-- I guess
they just strong-armed it,
if we're going to be honest.
JD STIER: Trevor Noah said that
Kabila found a really easy way
to stay in power, and it's
to not hold elections.
And there are some
very stark similarities
between the United
States government
today and the
Congolese government
and this kleptocratic
form of rule,
where you enrich yourself and
your immediate family members
and buy off or intimidate
or suppress the opposition.
Kabila's tactics are
starting to look very similar
in our own White House.
In addition to--
I'd say since December 19
when President Kabila ignored
his constitutional mandate
to leave the presidency,
he's been buying off the more
prominent opposition members.
And so at a time when the
elite are consolidating power
and increasingly
suppressing, Stand With Congo
had recently released
a series of videos
of young, nonviolent,
pro-democracy activists.
Many of them are
individuals your age who've
graduated with law degrees
and medical degrees,
and there are no economic
opportunities for them at home.
They've decided to join
a social movement, which
looks very akin to
Black Lives Matter here,
very akin to the
Anti-Apartheid Movement,
the Civil Rights
Movement in this country,
and are calling
out for elections.
They're getting
increasingly organized
throughout the country.
And so what we're
hoping to support
is really this
confluence of factors
of the elite
consolidating power,
but a growing sentiment
demanding elections.
And with the youth
movement throughout country
active in six provinces,
there is still
some hope that given the
fact that Kabila is extremely
unpopular broadly throughout
the whole country,
that if the public can be tapped
into by those brave enough
to take action, that there
is yet hope this year.
And so we all are engaged
in standing in solidarity
and supporting the
youth movement,
as are local church leaders--
a voice that's necessary
to show unity--
the few remaining opposition MPs
that have not been bought off
by Kabila, and civil society.
Congo has one of the
strongest and most developed
civil societies on the
continent and in the world.
And they've been
increasingly organized
and effective in
recent years, and there
is a lot of courage to
speak out about corruption
throughout the Congo.
And so there is
some hope, and there
are individuals in
the country that we've
worked with that are
leading that charge
and trying to raise up
that message of hope
for their countrymen and women.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
Thank you very much for
coming to give this screening.
My question is how
much of a record trail
is available for where
the minerals are going
and who's benefiting from them.
I know you mentioned Apple
and a couple other tech
companies that have
done their research
to try to find out
how they're connected
to the minerals in Congo
and to make changes,
but how much of a record trail
is there that is accessible.
I feel like that'd be
a really good place
to start, to surface
that information
and show the culpability
of all the players
in the tech industry,
including all of us,
by the way, because we are
consumers of tech products.
JD STIER: On our website,
StandWithCongo.org,
we have reports that have
extensive documentation.
We have some leading
organizations,
from Kofi Annan's
Africa Progress
Panel to Global Witness,
really the world's
leading transparency
organization.
Both of these are NGOs,
civil society organizations.
If you really plug
into the news,
you'll remember about
a year ago there
was a scandal called
the Panama Papers.
And so it was a legal
entity in Panama
that set up myriad offshore bank
accounts for corrupt business
dealings.
And President
Kabila, his sister,
and many of his family members
showed up in those documents,
and so there was a
real watershed moment
for having it in writing and
seeing some of the ledgers.
But if you go to
our website, you're
going to get to see from Africa
Progress Panel to Bloomberg
to Global Witness and
others the paper trail,
and there are some groups that
have done amazing research
and documentation.
Bloomberg's lead the
way, Global Witness
has used much of their reporting
to enhance their reports,
and locally here, there's an
NGO in Washington DC called
the Enough Project.
And there are individuals
within your corporation
that are working
with Enough Project
to show the steps that
Google is taking, and I had--
I worked at the Enough
Project from 2011 to 2014
while I was producing
this film, and I
was leading the consumer
tech conflict-free
push that resulted
in Apple and Intel
and some others
taking some big steps.
I spoke with my colleagues
who continue that work
and continue to rank the
world's leading tech companies,
and they had good things
to say about Google.
But this will be
the very first time
you're included in those
rankings, which are set
to come out in the near future.
And so those are
some great resources,
and all of those organizations
and all of those resources
are published on our
website, StandWithCongo.org.
KWAME MARFO: And I would add--
so there's actually a longer
version of this documentary--
which you watch on Netflix--
which highlights a
number of other entities.
So it's not just tech.
Looking at Congo, it has
virtually almost any resource
that you could think of.
You know what I mean?
So you have countries
like Rwanda,
which has over a couple of
years been sort of raiding Congo
every now and then.
So it cuts across
various sectors.
You have multiple state and
non-state actors involved.
And that actually feeds into
that title for the documentary,
which is when you have different
players, heavyweights, fighting
over resources, the
little ones are the ones
whose rights get trampled upon.
So it's across from mining to--
you name it.
Everyone has had a stake in
the Congo historically and now.
But there is a ton of
information available
that we're happy
to share with you
on the back of this
documentary if you're
keen on helping follow the
trail and joining this advocacy
movement to promote transparency
in mining in the Congo.
AUDIENCE: Hi, thank
you for coming
to share your time and
your information with us.
So I was curious
about whether there's
been any progress on the
governmental or policy side
where these minerals are going.
Because I can
imagine how hard it
is to change things in Congo
because there's a lot of flux
there.
But has there been any progress
over the years in terms
of countries where the minerals
are going creating policies
to actually prevent minerals
coming in from places where
they're sourced illegally?
KWAME MARFO: Is this specific
to the Congo only or--?
AUDIENCE: Well,
it's specifically
to the Congo in this context
but also just generally.
JD STIER: I can speak
to Congo, and then you
can speak to Africa, or
the other way around.
KWAME MARFO: Right.
Yeah.
Absolutely.
AUDIENCE: So you have countries
like the US or Belgium or--?
JD STIER: Sure I'll
touch on Congo specific,
and then Kwame can broaden
it to the continent resources
at large.
You saw early on in the film,
which is available on Netflix.
So please feel free--
I think if you're asking
people to sign a petition,
just include a link to the film.
They can watch it on
Netflix, but it's also
available worldwide on Amazon.
So we just want it
to get out there
for free or for
a couple of bucks
to anyone who wants to
learn about this issue
or is willing to kind
of hear what you've
been learned about today.
In the film, they
really broke down--
which is a very complex sector
and one of the largest mining
sectors on earth--
into the east of Congo
and the south of Congo.
And as you heard,
the human atrocities
are unparalleled in the east.
Conservative estimates say
that over 6 million people have
died since the 1996
war in the east,
and many experts agree
it's many millions more.
There's myriad armed groups,
dozens of semi-autonomous armed
groups.
Yes, a few of the biggest,
most well-funded groups
are Rwandan backed.
Uganda plays a role
in that as well,
and the Congolese elites
have a role in some
of those groups as well.
In that melee of
competing armed groups,
the humans on the ground are the
ones paying the price for that.
They use sexual violence as a
tactic of war, intimidation,
child soldier recruitment,
and other human atrocities,
mass atrocities, to control
those mineral areas.
Now the human rights
push originating
in Congo with youth movement
leaders that I mentioned--
LUCHA is the French acronym
"fight for change"--
it is an entity that's
really been leading
the push for transparency
and for better
governance on the ground.
They've been joined by
Congolese living in the diaspora
and international
citizens in solidarity,
and this is where this
large push since 2010,
2011, has resulted in some
of the world's major tech
companies taking aim.
And by having Intel, Motorola
Solutions, and others actually
go visit with
mineral mining rights
associations and Congolese
civil society organizations,
whereas five years
ago, there were
no certified mines
in the east, there
are now many dozens of
certified mines in the east.
I was there in January
with our film team,
and we visited one of the
largest mines in eastern Congo.
There's a minimum wage,
there's safety requirements,
there are labor requirements,
there are no more
children working in
the mines, and you're
seeing this type of operation
spreading in the east.
And it's happening because
there's solidarity,
because you have some large
purchasers in the West,
like yourselves,
joining a coalition,
joining conversation,
Congolese-led solutions
on the ground.
There is no shortage of
Congolese entrepreneurs
that want to do sustainable
long term and safe business.
It's the corruption
and the armed groups
that get in the way.
But when you have a critical
mass of stakeholders
come together, the
unity is strong enough
where they can pilot
and now flourish
with conflict-free models.
This extends beyond
mining in the east.
There's Congo coffee
peace project.
A former rebel commander,
General [? Cassango ?] is now
a part of a 2,500 person-strong
fair trade coffee operation,
which fills up a large, Masisi--
area of the Masisi
province north of Goma.
This is 2,500 men that used to
be in local armed groups that
are now all working in the
coffee trade, fair trade coffee
trade.
There's almost no violence and
no theft in Masisi anymore,
and everybody has a
reliable full time income.
And so this push
and really the need
for some international
solidarity--
and not just civil society
leaders and business
leaders like ourselves--
but corporations
and powerful entities showing an
interest changes the dynamics.
I remember getting a call
from Fidel Bafilemba,
a prominent activist
featured throughout the film.
One of the leading experts
on mining and transparency
in the east gave me a call
shortly after the Intel
presentation at the Consumer
Electronics Show in January
2013 said that he got a
call from one of the most
notorious armed commanders
in Congo and said, Fidel,
I know you're working with
these people in the West
and these companies.
If someone wanted to
hire me and my men
to be like a
security contractor,
we're open for that.
And so even from
who we would want
to call the bad guys
of which there's
nothing that simple and
nothing black and white,
and from many child soldiers
and army commanders and soldiers
that I've met and gotten to
know their stories pretty well,
a pretty common scenario
is your mother is raped,
your father is killed,
and you're recruited.
And so when we take a
look back at the influence
and the corruption, it's just
not black and white and good
guys and bad guys.
It's much more complex
and nuanced than that,
and the one uniting factor and
a real strong reason for hope
is development.
It's business development,
it's transparency,
and it's having a reliable, safe
way to make your livelihood.
And the appetite is so strong.
Now it gets to the other part
of my answer to your question,
and that's kind of some of
the good news in the east.
The south, where Bloomberg
analysts referred
to as the real money, the
billion dollar deals, that's
handled by Kabila
and his regime,
Gecamines, the state
mining industry.
Very little signs
of progress, and I'd
just almost love to say, no.
There's no progress.
Global Witness, a British-based
transparency organization
that you can find
through our website,
continues to document instances
of multimillion dollar bribes
from Glencore, which
is based in the UK.
If you look in, some of
their major shareholders
are our own American-based
retirement funds
that we select for our 401ks.
There's a lot of pressure
we could put, especially
through shareholders,
on Glencore.
Glencore is one of the major
financiers of the Kabila
regime, his family, maintaining
the status quo of corruption.
Congo-- in just a
couple of years,
looking at just a few
deals, the Congolese people
lost over a billion
dollars to corrupt deals
whereas President
Kabila would personally
get a bribe in the
millions of dollars
and then sell off Congolese
mining concessions
at billions under market value.
That practice continues
today, and that's
what many experts agree
is the reason why he's
ignoring the Constitution
and is relatively immune
from international pressure.
He has a virtual blank check.
And that's all connected
to our mining industry
and the minerals that we
rely on in our industries
and in our lives.
And so while public pressure
has improved some conditions
in the east and there an
increasing number of certified
conflict-free minds and other
entrepreneurial ventures
in the east, the state
as a whole and the sector
in the south, where the
real money has been made,
I think is the thing that
we need to continue to focus
on, and we're going to continue
to advocate for and look
for increasing partnerships
for, but really put pressure
on the Western
mining companies--
Glencore chief among them--
to end their support
of the Kabila regime
and for really being the
root of corruption in Congo.
KWAME MARFO: Quickly,
so within a continent,
I know a number of countries--
I know Ghana, for example--
recently discovered oil
and has been exporting.
In terms of petroleum bills,
we actually got a bit of help
from Norway in terms of
building up our capacity.
So on paper, we have some
quote "best practices."
But in practice,
[INAUDIBLE] events in Ghana,
we're doing really well.
GDP growing at 8%.
For five years, we discovered
a new and economy imploded.
So when the rubber
did hit a tire,
the resource infrastructure
has been deemed to be 110.
I know countries like Botswana
has done a pretty good job.
Senegal recently
discovered large deposits
of natural resources,
and there's
conversation around doing that.
Outside of Africa,
I know it was--
so with the last
US administration,
so during the passage of the
Dodd-Frank Financial Reform
Bill--
so there's a provision in
it which basically requests
that companies doing mining
to publish what they pay,
which is designed to
bring transparency.
And US taking that initiative
led the EU and Canada, which
I believe collectively
make up 75% of revenue
generated within the
sector, to also raise
the bar for companies
operating in these regions
to publish what they pay to
expose any corrupt practices.
Unfortunately, the
new administration
here in the United States is
looking at reversing this bill.
The good thing is I think this
went through Congress so it
cannot be unwound through
an executive action.
It would have to go
through Congress.
But we know the current
Secretary of State
has been in favor of
this bill, a good number
of the Senators on the other
side of the political spectrum
were on the same
side as the President
now so not very much in favor.
So I guess we're in
watch and see mode.
We also had a
conversation with the UN,
UNDP, about three
weeks ago, and there
is a conversation around the
screening this documentary
and what the UN is doing.
And part of what really
piqued their interest
with this documentary
is they've been
spend a lot of time working with
countries that have recently
discovered natural resources to
help build up their capacity.
That said, I think most of
the current bills in place
have been largely focused
on natural resources
and how to make
the most out of it.
Unfortunately, I
think the challenge
and why I think these
bills aren't really working
is the focus has been
largely on the resources
and how to get the best
price, how to negotiate.
My view-- and this
is one thing we've
been working with
JD to get across--
is Africa's most valuable
resources are not
what lies underneath the Earth.
They're hiding in plain sight.
It's just people.
So to the extent that we could
engage policy makers to channel
these resources towards
investing in the human capital,
I think that will be
the right way to go.
So most of the
current conversations
I've been around setting
up sovereign wealth funds,
trying to find ways to
increase the bargaining powers,
and it's all a bit
resource-focused.
I think if we could channel
that discussion away from,
you know, to
investing in people I
think that can drive
the change and lead
to more sustainable
growth on the continent.
JD STIER: We're really grateful
to have this opportunity
and get to speak about a more
hopeful future and a way we can
work together to achieve that.
If there's a small
part of you that
would be open to exploring a
way that you can help out--
you know whether it's
signing a petition
and sharing a petition, helping
raise awareness, explore
some innovative ways that we
can engage students and youth--
if you're interested in that
or if you want to explore ways
to give direct support
or you can rally
some folks on your team
or more broadly here
for some direct support,
please take my card before you
leave the room.
We're really grateful
to have had opportunity.
For all of you watching it
online and for those of you
here in the room,
thank you very much,
and we want to just have some
closing remarks from Jim.
So thank you all very much.
JIM N.: [INAUDIBLE] thank you
all for watching this film.
And again, as JD said if
you want more information,
want to know how you
can help further,
definitely a lot of great
resources on the website.
Again, I just want to add again
I was in Congo last month.
It was my first
time in 19 years.
So it was my first time
going there as an adult,
and basically, one thing
that's common in the people
you talk to is that there's just
frustration and exasperation
because everybody wants to work.
People want opportunities,
but a lot of time,
there's powers that
be that pretty much
prevent them from building their
version of the Congolese dream,
if you'd say.
So basically, I just want you
to be aware that the Congolese--
I think as a Congolese
sometimes you're kind of worried
about these documentaries
because it's
like your people are painted
as helpless folks just looking
for help, looking for
outsiders to intervene.
That's not the case.
There are Congolese
solutions on the ground.
There are Congolese who
really want to work,
but there are powers that be a
lot of times from very wealthy
interests with big money, real
money, that really cannot--
that really would be hurt by
Congo taking control of its
resources.
So there's a lot of
major interests at heart.
So it's really important
that to just also
be aware that the Congolese--
I just want to make
sure that people
don't leave this
thinking, poor Congo,
I feel bad for the Congolese.
They're in really bad shape.
There are some problems, but
also there's a lot of pride
there.
And as Congolese, we definitely
want to make sure that people--
that perception of us as a
poor, helpless bunch of people
doesn't exist, that we don't--
we want to make sure that kind
of stops.
But that if you want to support
that, again, you check out
the resources, make
sure you understand
where your 401ks going,
that you make sure
that if you want to support
an activist, then do that.
And also one last thing
specifically to Google--
when I was in Congo basically,
the American Chamber
of Commerce told me
that Google will be
going to Congo this December.
They'll be helping set
up some fiber optics,
I guess wiring and cables to
make for Wi-Fi connectivity.
So again, I don't know how close
Google here and Google in Congo
works but basically, I think
it will be great if when
Google is in the
country that they make
sure that they employ locals.
A lot of times foreign
companies they go elsewhere,
and they just bring
their people with them,
and they don't have as
much as big of an impact
as they could in a
local population.
So basically, if any
of you are interested
or are aware of how Google
Congo would operate,
I definitely want to encourage
you to maybe talk to your team,
talk to your leaders
and make sure
that there is a plan
in place to ensure
that when goes is in
Congo, it has as much
of a positive effect as it can.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]